how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how do
I get in we're in a situation today
which is very very unusual in the
history of civilization a survey last
year showed that the majority of people
in Britain say they have no religion
there had been very very few
civilizations where most people have had
no religion it happened in the Soviet
Union and in the communist countries
where religion was forcibly suppressed
but it's not because it's been forcibly
suppressed here
and the percentage of people who
actually go to church on a regular basis
is now in Britain about 5% it's similar
in France and Sweden in some countries
in Europe it's a bit higher 12% in some
but it's very very low most of Europe is
now described by many people as post
Christian so does this mean that most
people have become atheists well the
answer is no the surveys also showed
that the percentage of atheists and the
population is about 13% here in Britain
so together with the number of people
who are regularly religious and atheists
they're less than 20% so 80% of people
and neither identifying as religious nor
as atheists and it what happens in the
middle for most people the interest in
spirituality hasn't gone away
in fact there's probably more interest
in spirituality now than ever before in
terms of actual practices by which one
can experience spiritual realities and
by spiritual realities I mean a sense of
connection with the consciousness
greater than our own now for some people
that sense of connection is just a trick
played by the brain something going on
inside the head but for most people it's
the feeling that our consciousness is
indeed part of some greater
consciousness or can connect with it or
greater consciousness is because there
may be many
at the same time there's also been in
the last 25 years a lot of
investigations scientifically of
spiritual practices some of these are of
brain scans and physiology some of them
are social science studies of the
effects of spiritual practices in 2001
an enormous volume called the handbook
of religion and health came out
reviewing about 1500 papers in
peer-reviewed journals about religious
and spiritual practices and in 2012 vol
2 reviewed a further and nearly 2,000
papers and these are huge volumes and a
huge amount of research about 4 percent
of these papers found that religious
practices could make people feel worse
and these were for people who lived in a
state of religious conflict or who felt
incredibly guilty and belonged to
religions that made them feel even
guiltier but the great majority of these
studies showed beneficial effects
basically they showed that people who
have religious and spiritual practices
are happier healthier and live longer
the effects on lifespan were quite
dramatic and as some people have said if
any pill were discovered that had these
effects it would be hailed as a wonder
drug these findings have not been lost
on atheists the atheist writer and
philosopher Alain de Botton
brought out a book three or four years
ago called religion for atheists and
what de Botton says in that book is that
he himself was raised atheist his
parents were Jewish living in
Switzerland and were fanatically
atheistic he said that if anyone showed
the slightest interest in religion his
parents treated them as if they were
suffering from some terminal
degenerative disease and never took them
seriously thereafter and so he said he
was raised atheist he accepts his
parental faith but he's not interested
in fighting religion but in atheism to
point not what happens when you've given
that religion you no longer gather in a
sacred place you no longer have seen
together with members of your community
you no longer celebrate festivals you
miss out on rites of passage you no
longer go on pilgrimages you no longer
hear sermons which are talks designed to
help you lead a better life and you no
longer have love feasts or agaves you no
longer have temples
well he's planning to build an atheist
temple in London he inherited 200
million pounds so that makes it easier
and he's started a series of atheist
sermons on Sunday mornings in London and
also trying out atheist love feasts
meanwhile other prominent atheists
including Susan Blackmore who's at this
festival meditators and she's been doing
Zen meditation for years and Sam Harris
who's one of the so called new atheists
in America is now giving online
meditation courses because it helps
people it's a serious help in people's
lives also two three years ago a group
of people in England founded an atheist
church called the Sunday assembly it now
has more than 70 branches they meet on
Sunday mornings sing happy songs tell
uplifting stories and in fact they've
rebranded it they don't want to be
called an atheist church anymore they
prefer it to be called mystical humanism
so religions are being reinvented right
now and spiritual practices are
receiving a great deal of scientific
attention in my book science and
spiritual practices I discuss seven
there are many different practices but
that I discuss seven gratitude
meditation been a great deal of research
on meditation singing and chanting it
says something I've learned a lot about
from my wife Joe Perce who gives
wonderful singing enchanting workshops
and one other thing I learned from Joe
which is an inspiration for this book is
that the people who come to her workshop
some are non-religious some are
religious it doesn't matter you can do
these practices whatever your belief
system it's about experience
about signing up to a belief and joel's
workshops take one to the very heart of
the effect of the voice on the body of
the vibrations it sets up in the body
the effects of chanting with other
people where you come into resonance
with a whole group of people literal
resonance so that's another practice I
discuss connecting with nature relating
to plants which is favorite one of mine
it's the kind of spillover from
connecting and with nature it wouldn't
all fit in one chapter pilgrimage is one
of the really important practices that
I'm talking about and I'll say more
about that now and rituals so these are
practices found in all religious
traditions and which can be experienced
outside them as well and we now in
Britain have access to the whole of the
world's religious traditions and
spiritual traditions three or four
hundred years ago no one would have
heard of the shamanic use of ayahuasca
in South America or shamanic drumming in
Native American tribes or Buddhist
meditation or Zen and Tibetan Buddhist
practices all these things were unknown
so was most about Hinduism and people
were aware of Islam but not much more
than Judaism but not much more we're in
a situation where you can do any of
these practices there are teachers and
people from all these traditions living
here in Britain so it's a new situation
I'm going to talk I don't have time to
talk about them all but I'm going to
talk about a few of these practices and
I'll start with gratitude this is in a
way the simplest gratitude has now been
studied by positive psychologists and
some of you are probably aware of the
positive psychology movement it's been
going for what 20 or 30 years and this
is a movement among psychologists who
are trying to find out what makes people
happy what makes it a radical departure
from traditional psychologists that most
of it was about what makes people
miserable because psychotherapists after
all mostly see people who are miserable
and so there's a lot of studies on what
makes people miserable
but the positive psychology movement set
out to find out why up he what makes
people happy they started with a series
of studies in which people had beepers
which went off at random times and they
had to write down what they were doing
and what how happy they felt on a one to
nine scale and it turned out that people
throughout the day their level of
happiness varied of course but the
activities they were involved in when
they were happy were very varied
sometimes when they really absorbed in
their work sometimes from their having a
great conversation sometimes in their
making love sometimes when they're
dancing or singing sometimes when
they're playing games the common thing
with all these was that they were in a
state of flow and that's what made them
feel happy what made them feel unhappy
was boredom disconnection separation
isolation disconnection from what's
happening
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival how the
light gets in org